[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an american family comedy film
called the parent trap
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie begins with children arriving
at camp walden for an eight-week-long
all-girls summer camp the girls seem
overjoyed to be camping next to moose
lake
hallie parker is an eleven-year-old girl
from northern california hallie's father
nick parker owns a huge vineyard hallie
quickly befriends two girls at the camp
meanwhile annie is an 11 year old girl
from london annie's mother elizabeth
james is a famous wedding gown designer
annie's family butler martin drops her
at the camp they share an intricate
handshake before parting ways although
hallie and annie have contrasting
characters they both look identical
annie is prim and proper while hallie is
more carefree at the camp the two girls
go head to head in a fencing match
unaware of their uncanny identicalness
both the girls are extremely gifted at
fencing and give each other a good
competition in the end annie triumphs
and inadvertently pushes hallie into the
water with her last move and he quickly
apologizes and offers her hand to halle
however hallie takes her hand and pulls
annie into the water with her when the
two girls take their fencing masks off
they are awestruck to learn that they
look identical hallie quickly snaps out
of it and insults annie the two girls
argue and almost get physical when the
camp counselor breaks them up
later the two little girls again butt
heads over a game of poker halle
proposes a punishment that whoever loses
the game will have to jump in moose lake
naked and he confidently accepts the
challenge but hallie beats her with a
royal flush annie is then forced to jump
in the lake after which hallie and her
friends steal annie's clothes and run
away when annie learns that hallie
tricked her she vows to take revenge the
comical hostility between the two girls
leads to a prank war that ends when the
camp counselors fall into one of
halley's traps and isolate the twins
from the other girls the two girls are
told to pack their bags and sent to live
together in the isolation cabin as
punishment the two girls continue to
clash with each other however they soon
become close after annie helps hallie
close the jammed window they tell each
other about their homes and families
annie hasn't had a dad in her life since
her dad and mother got divorced when she
was little while halle doesn't have a
mother and she lives with her dad after
learning that the two also share the
same birthday annie starts suspecting
that all of this can't be mere
coincidence annie and halle then show
each other the only pictures of their
father and mother that they have it
turns out each has half of a torn
wedding photograph of their parents they
realize annie and halle are actual twin
sisters they are elated by the discovery
they tape their parents half torn
picture back together and spend hours
together learning about their mother and
father as the end of the summer camp
approaches they long to know more about
their parents so halle then proposes an
idea she suggests they switch places and
go back home as one another annie tells
her that they will immediately get
caught but hallie insists that they will
be able to pull it off as they both look
identical and they can learn how to
imitate each other moreover even if they
get caught sooner or later their parents
will have to meet face to face because
of it the two girls then spend their
remaining time at the camp learning and
practicing each other's mannerisms they
learn about each other's house's
blueprint hallie learns annie's
intricate handshake while annie cuts her
hair and gets her ears pierced with a
hot needle the summer camp comes to an
end and the twins put their plan into
action hallie goes back to london as
annie she perfectly impersonates annie
effortlessly imitating annie's handshake
and mannerism so much that annie's
butler martin is not able to tell the
difference
halle is elated to meet her mother and
maternal grandfather charles for the
first time she hugs them tightly which
surprises elizabeth she tags along with
elizabeth to her work to spend more time
with her at an opportune time hallie
broaches the topic of her father nick
she asks elizabeth if she remembers him
and how they met elizabeth is surprised
by the sudden curiosity but tells hallie
about nick she says that nick was a
lovely guy and they met aboard the queen
elizabeth 2 or qe2 an ocean liner that
sails from london to new york they were
traveling on a ship because both nick
and elizabeth weren't keen on flying
they were seated next to each other for
dinner on the first night of their
voyage meanwhile annie pretends to be
hallie and goes to california she's
overjoyed to meet her father the little
girl can't believe that she's talking to
her father she even keeps calling him
dad in every other sentence due to
excitement annie is greeted at home by
halley's lovely nanny chessy and dog
sammy chessy isn't able to tell the
difference between annie and halle but
sammy seems to have caught on to annie's
charade and keeps barking at her annie's
excitement soon subsides when she comes
to know about nick's new young fiance
meredith blake
nick and meredith seem very into each
other however chessy speculates that
meredith is only after nick's money
annie herself grows to dislike meredith
after getting a feel of her selfish ways
the next day nick finally asks annie how
she would feel if meredith becomes a
part of their family feigning her
ignorance annie responds that she would
love it she adds that she also wanted a
big sister and now nick is about to
adopt meredith
bern
but nick quickly corrects her and
reveals that he is actually going to
marry meredith left with no choice and
forced to acknowledge annie responds
negatively and screams in french a
language hallie doesn't know nick is
surprised by her behavior but meredith
assures him that it is normal and
expected of a child whose father is
getting remarried meredith then goes to
talk to annie she pretends to empathize
with annie but annie sees through
meredith's charade and cuts her short
annie acknowledges that meredith is
young beautiful sexy and perhaps that's
what attracts her dad after all he's
only human but she adds marriage should
be more than just sex
seeing her charming strategy terribly
fail on annie meredith drops her
pretense she candidly tells annie that
nick and her are getting married in two
weeks whether annie likes it or not and
she needs to get over it distressed by
meredith's deviousness annie telephones
halle annie tells her twin sister about
their father's impending wedding annie
persuades her to bring elizabeth to
california to break up the engagement
however charles catches hallie on the
phone charles forces her to come clean
to her mother immediately hallie is
scared but she tells elizabeth
everything she apologizes to elizabeth
for deceiving her but instead of
scolding the little girl elizabeth gets
emotional and embraces her daughter
meanwhile in california chessy too
figures out that it's annie and not
halle there soon everyone finds out
about it except for nick and meredith
who remain unaware of the switch hallie
convinces elizabeth to fly to california
to meet nick and fix their relationship
but she keeps elizabeth in the dark
about nick's engagement and tells her
that nick is eager to meet her even
after all these years elizabeth still
seems to be in love with nick
nervous about meeting him elizabeth asks
martin to accompany hallie and her as a
friend to bring nick and elizabeth
together halle annie chessy martin and
charles conspire to have them meet at a
hotel in san francisco nick is scheduled
to meet meredith's parents at the same
hotel elizabeth runs into nick with
meredith at the hotel elevator she gets
suspicious and confronts her twin
daughters the two girls come clean and
reveal that nick is engaged and getting
married in two weeks annie tells her mum
that she can't let it happen but
elizabeth hurt responds that nick and
her have nothing in common anymore she
then continues by saying that nick seems
to be happy with his fiancee putting her
foot down elizabeth adds that she will
do what she came to do and will fly back
to london with annie however nick is
elated to have run into elizabeth after
so many years he looks for her
throughout the hotel when he finally
notices her he accidentally falls in the
pool in excitement just as nick breaks
the ice between elizabeth and him annie
and tally arrive they come clean about
the switch although a bit taken aback by
the revelation nick becomes overjoyed
and emotional to see his other daughter
after 11 years meredith too soon catches
up with the development to her dismay
later that evening the two girls give
their parents a surprise it is a
candlelit dinner served by chessy and
martin on a yacht decorated to recreate
their first meeting aboard the queen
elizabeth ii nick and elizabeth
reminisce about their past times spent
together both good and bad it is
revealed that elizabeth left nick after
they had a huge argument they were both
young stupid and had bad tempers back
then they said hurtful things to each
other elizabeth expresses slight sadness
over nick not following her after she
left neck responds that he was not sure
if elizabeth wanted him to they finally
make plans for the girls to spend
holidays together but decide against
resuming their relationship dismayed but
determined hallie and annie vow not to
leave each other the two girls hatch a
plan the next day they wear similar
dresses to confuse their parents and
refuse to reveal which twin is which as
elizabeth gets ready to leave for london
the twin girls put forth a condition
where the four of them would have to go
on a camping trip only after which will
they reveal their identity initially
reluctant nick and elizabeth finally
agree to take them on the camping trip
as expected meredith isn't happy with
the trip and insists on tagging along
despite neck being hesitant elizabeth
invites meredith to go camping with nick
and the girls while she waits behind at
the parker residence the four then take
off and start hiking meredith isn't used
to the altitude and soon gets tired the
girls take advantage of that and play
various tricks on meredith when she
stops to take a rest they put heavy
stones in her backpack and scare her
with a lizard meredith had a hard time
carrying her bags and the two girls
offer to help her meredith rudely
declines and says that she sees through
the two girls angelic faces she
threatens to make their lives miserable
after she gets married to their dad if
they play one more trick on her but the
girls continue to prank her at night
meredith who is tired of hiking and
dealing with the two sisters plants a
long kiss on nick before taking a
sleeping pill and going to bed early
later after nick goes to sleep annie and
halle dragon asleep meredith with her
inflatable airbed into the lake meredith
wakes up the next morning in the middle
of the lake by a bird she freaks out and
falls into the water meredith finally
loses her patience and angrily gives
nick an ultimatum to choose between her
or his daughters nick finally realizes
meredith's bad attitude and gets to know
that his daughters won't be fine with
her hence he chooses the girls over
meredith without thinking much and
breaks off the engagement although annie
and halle are both punished for their
shenanigans they accept it as they got
rid of meredith for good elizabeth
apologizes to nick for inviting meredith
on the trip and breaking their
engagement nick jokingly responds that
he knows that elizabeth deliberately
tricked meredith into going camping with
hallie and danny later that night after
putting the girls to bed nick shows
elizabeth his wine collection it
includes a 1983 wine that they drank at
their wedding elizabeth gets emotional
but tries to put on a strong face nick
tells her that she doesn't always have
to be brave
they get drawn to almost kiss but
elizabeth holds back she is almost in
tears by the encounter but decides to
ignore it a hesitant nick then puts the
wine back later the four of them are
saying their emotional goodbyes as they
hug each other elizabeth then returns to
london with annie as the rain pours down
annie is dejected after being separated
from her sister and father again however
when annie and elizabeth get home they
find hallie and nick waiting for them
nick and halle flew to london on the
concorde which cuts travel time by half
compared to general passenger planes
they explained that they had realized
they didn't want to lose annie and
elizabeth again nick tells elizabeth
that he made the mistake of not coming
after her once and he is not going to
make that mistake again elizabeth is
fearful of remarrying but she yields to
nick's unwavering confidence and hallie
and annie look on happily as their
parents embrace the ending shows nick
and elizabeth getting remarried aboard
the qe2 with the girls as bridesmaids
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching